Take it there, take it there!
Yeah!
Oh!
8-5.
I'm going this way.
How about it?
It was there.
Good play.
Holding, holding.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Come back, come back!
Yeah, come back!
Come on, come on, come on!
Come on, come on!
Open, open!
Yep.
Woo!
There we go!
Good thing, good thing.
There's no time.
There's no time to double-bag.
It's a wave.
You've got one shot at it.
Holding.
Good ball.
Yeah, come back, come back, come back!
Go on, go on, go on!
Score, Cal, score, Cal!
In the act of the score.
I'll give you that one.
9-6.
Yeah, Corey, here we go.
2-1.
Come on, come on!
Defense, defense, defense!
We're up here!
Pass that out!
Come on, come on!
Pass!
We're down here!
Oh, no!
Congratulations.
9-4, I've stopped them.
9-7!
18, one to go!
Come back on!
Yeah.
Good luck!
Come back, guys!
Come back, baby, come back!
Drop, drop, drop!
Hey, just ain't set up!
That's true, it's true!
My bad, man.
Oh!
I gotcha!
9-8!
Nice line, Brendan!
That was it.
Holding!
Come on, back, get back guys, get back, get back!
Back!
Get back, get back!
Good job, bro.
Defense, defense, defense!
State, defense, defense!
Take him down!
Ohhhhh!
We gotta win!
No, he apparently is all about
fucking...